あの だいたいまあこの月例講演会っていうのは
あの まあ最初に考えたのに
まあ仏教のことを何も知らない方々にまあ紹介的に
まあ悪く言えば宣伝的に
あの まあコマーシャルやろうではないかなと
まあどんどん中身が深くなってしまってね
まあ元の目的から脱線していますけど
まあそれでもできるだけまあ軽く喋りたいとは思ってます
で 心のおしゃべりはエンドレスということで
あの ブッダは沈黙の聖者ですと
で まあまあ テーマについて考えると
まあ面白いことはね 私たちはずっと頭の中で喋ってるんですね
終わりなく喋ってるんです
しかし 仏教が目指す境地っていうのは
それそちらの反対で 沈黙ということなんですね
まあそれはどういうことかと
で なんで沈黙はそんなに大事でしょうかと
まあわかりやすいと思いますね
私たちは頭の中で喋っていて
もう大変な不幸になっているんです
もう止まることできなくて
もうまあごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃと喋ってるんですね
それでもどんどんどんどん精神的な力がね
なくなっていくんです
なくなっていくと 体の力もなくなっていくんです
体の機能が衰えていくと
当然脳の機能もダメージを受けるんですね
で まあ変なものを考えたんだからといって
突然脳が悪くなるわけじゃないんですが
まあそれで脳が反応を起こしますから
それは体にダメージを与えて
体からまた逆に逆流して
脳っていうのは体の一部ですからね
で 一緒に壊れてしまうんですね
で まあ復活はできますが
あまり世間がね 脳の復活の方はあまりわからないんですね
まあ最近ですね いくらか脳のことをいろいろ喋るようになりましたのは
体の体力を維持することにしたことだけは世の中知ってますけど
でも そんなことをやっても
ずっと頭の中でね 変なことを喋りだしっぱなしですから
これがまあなかなか終わりきれないんですね
で それで体が弱くなっていて
脳も弱くなっていって
もう最後に精神的にひどい病気に陥っちゃうんですね
なんでみんな病気に陥らないのかというと
私たちはいろいろもう嫌で嫌で仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから仕事をしたり 大事なことをしたりすると
余計なおしゃべりは一旦コントロールされますね
それで助かっているんです
では 仕事もなく やることもなく
2  3週間ぐらいいてみてください
どうなるのかと かなり壊れてきますよ
で それですっごく忙しい人々はね
まあ結構元気なんですね
すごい忙しいという 理由はもうおしゃべり時間がないんですね
で 説明しますけど まああの
このおしゃべりといっても
もうかなり無駄な 感情的な
ネガティブな 自己破壊的なことばっかり頭で喋ってるんですね
情報は入れないんですね
いるんですからね 自分一人勝手に考えて
世界もそのようなものであると思っている人々もいるんですね
そういう人々がいるだけでもすごい迷惑なんですね
何か勝手に考えることしか知りませんし
世界の人の関係はないし
しかし迷惑をかけようとしておるんですね
だから情報に感覚器官を開けておかないんですね
これはかなり現実離れになりまして
妄想だけになっちゃって
それから脳が幻覚まで引き起こして
壊れていきます  そういうことで
またあの喋ってる間で体が動かないんです
口で喋ってるだけじゃないんです
頭で喋ってる時でも 微妙に調べてみてください
あのヴィパッサナー瞑想はいくらか真面目になさっているならば
それぐらいの実験できると思いますよ
あの喋ってるあの瞬間で体が動いてないんですね
時々知らないままで もう何時間でもそのままいるんですね
自分気づかないんです
肉体が動いてないんだと
本人がすごく忙しいんです
頭の中で喋ってるんだから
これ まあもう誰か雇ってでもチェックした方がいいんです
自分が何もしないでいる時間と
何か体を動かして何かやっている時間はもうちゃんと分けて分けて分けてみてくださいと
8時  8時に始めたら もう 8時からもう何分何分何分何もしないでいたのかとかね
何か動かす体を動かした時間は何時何分でしょうかとかね
いとも簡単に発見できると思いますよ
かなりの時間動いてないんです
自分が気づかないんです
自分がものすごい暴走して仕事をしているんです
頭の中で いわゆるもう取り留めのない思考に絡んでいるんです
だから それ経済的に考えてみれば
いかにロスかと 思考自体も有意義ではないし
何か問題解決したわけでもないし
で 体を動かした方が経済的ですけど
動いてないんです だからそこを直せばもうたちまち幸福になりますよ
いきなり経済効果になります
その場合は人は何かするんですね
この何かをすることがまとめてみると
かなりの結果になります
この何かをする場合は
このあんまり無駄なことはやりたくはないんです
まあ例えば何かしようかな
じゃあ窓ガラスを まあ自分のアパートでは2枚しかないんだから
これ3時間かけて拭きましょうとかね
はしません 無駄なことはしませんよ
体でやる場合は 体でやる場合はいかに早く効率よくやるのかとするんです
頭ですね 無駄は ですから
この 無駄な喋りにふけってしまって
人類は  どんどんどんどん
いくら頑張っても同じところで走ってるだけでなっちゃうんですね
進めないんですね そういうことだから
まあ一般的に見ても これは結構大きな問題
精神的に病気になる問題で
人間が不幸になる問題で
勉強もできなくなっちゃうし
仕事もできなくなっちゃうし
家のこともできなくなるし
無駄で年取ってしまうんですね
はい そういうことだから
まあこうまあに入ります
初めは言葉がありということで
まあ有名な文句ですからね
これは何の意味もない言葉ですから
皆様はもうもう固く信じていると思います
頭の中は常に言葉がいっぱいですね
常に心の中で喋っているんです
そういうのは説明した通り
言葉とは初めからあるのではありません
あの相当頭がイカれているんですよ
初めは言葉がありという人の場合は
まあ言うまでもなく まあそういうことを書いたのは
みんな精神的には正常な人間ではないんだから
まあ文句を言うこともできませんだけど
まあ初めは言葉ありっていうのは
まあかなりイカれた言葉なんです
で 何やそれと どんな意味かいと
それで意味がないんだから
人間が信じるでしょうに
大事な言葉だよ その調子に乗ってるんですね
もうもう理不尽なことを屁理屈
もう支離滅裂ことを言っちゃえば
俺は神の言葉を言っていることことだと信じてくれるだろうと思うのは世間です
生まれてから徐々に言葉を学ぶでしょうに
言葉を持って生まれませんよ
これは後から学んだものなんです
であるならば 生命がね
我々我々より以前にいたとしたってもね
先に生命がいて それから言葉でしょう
やがて言葉が鎖になって
自分をエゴという柱に溶接されている状態になるんです
エゴに溶接されているんです
まあ鎖ですから 一応ぐるぐる回れます
しかし 逃げられません
で これどんな人間にも起こるプロセスなんですね
生まれた時は言葉がなかったんです
それから言葉を学んでいくんですね
学んでいくと 言葉がなんか独立
するんですね なんか今の事業仕分けでやっている
なんとかなんとか組織でありますね
あれ 何て言いますかね
あんな感じで独立しているという顔をしているんですけど
政府のお金で無駄遣いしているだけで
言葉は一番その組織なんですね
で 最初は自分 生きている自分が作ったものなんですけど
それが独立組織になるんですね
しかし 運営費はあなた払ってくださいと
私は暴走するそうと で
なんかどこかでフィリピンでしたっけね
まあ考えても 水をイリゲーションというプロジェクトでね
JICAでしたっけね
すっごくお金出しちゃって
で レポートではもうしっかり水は入ってますけど
向こうでは何もやってないんです
そのままもう土地も乾いたまんまで
億単位でしょ それで理由はどうでしょうかって言ったら
怒るだけであるいは言わないんですね
まあまあ そういうことで
まあ私たちも同じことをやってます
で 最初は言葉を作ったんだけど
もうなんとか訳があって言葉を作ったでしょ
それから言葉は独立組織になるんですね
特別法人になってしまってどうにもならないんですね
しかし こちらは必要な資金は全部出さなくちゃいけない
はい そういうことだから
なんか鎖にエゴというものに溶接されているんです
それで我々の頭の中で言葉がぐるぐるぐるぐる回る場合は
必ずエゴの回るエゴを中心にして回っているんです
言葉の使い方を学んでいましょう
ですから 我々は言葉の使い方
まず学ばなくてはいけないんです
で 体験と言葉 なんか見えないところもありますけど
五感から情報が触れると
それを体験するんですね
あるいは経験するんですね
することが知ることです
シンプルに考えてください
五感から五感に情報が触れるんですね
触れたら何か体験が起こるんです
体に だから正しい言葉は体験か経験かどちらかわかりませんだけど
まあ英語ではエクスペリエンスと言いますから
私はすぐ経験ということを書きますけど
漢字で見れば なんか経験もなんか怪しいなと
もう体験の方がいいんじゃないかなと思ったんですけど
まあどちらでもあまり気にしないでください
言葉のくされに引っかからないようにしてください
あの五感に情報が触れると
なんか我々はエクスペリエンスするんですね
感じるんですね わかりやすく言えば
これ認識というんですね
その経験が人の主観です
そこで目 耳 鼻に情報が触れると
なんか認識してしまうんですね
それは経験 体験というもので
知ることが起こるんですね
で この知ったことが それが私の主観であって
皆様方のも主観なんですね
それぞれ皆様にもセット一つ一つ個人的についてるでしょ
一度でも私の目を貸してくださいと言われたことがないんです
私も人に頼んだことがないんです
これ見たいんですけど
あなたの目を貸してくださいとかね
眼鏡を貸してもらっても
目はもう貸すことをできませんね
だから 自分には五感がセットついてます
で それは互いどういうことかさっぱりわからない
交換できません だから自分が経験するものは自分だけの経験であって
これには主観と言うんですね
それから他人とコミュニケーションをするために言葉を学ぶんです
これで私が生まれて赤ちゃん
皆様も赤ちゃんだと思ってください
で いろんなものが感じるでしょ
感じたことがなんとなく周りに表現したくなるんです
でも言葉がないんです
赤ちゃんがもう言葉二つしか持ってないでしょ
生まれつきは おぎゃーっと泣くことと
こちょこちょと笑うことですね
笑うことにしたっても
あまり音を立てて笑うことは知らないんです
だから まあそれも言葉というならば言葉なんですけど
で 笑う時もまあなんとなく喉からまあもう微かな声は聞こえますけど
まあ泣く時はまあ随分もう元気ですからね
もう防音の部屋の中にでも
あの音は届きますからね
はい それでなんで泣くのかっていうこと
お母さんわからないでしょうに
しかし 子供がちゃんと表現しているんですが
うまくいかないんですね
赤ちゃん何言ってるのかと
だからその不便さがお母さんにだけじゃないんですよ
子供は泣いてますけど
泣き止めませんよと 何やっても泣きやみ止めませんでどうしましょうか？とかね
言ってヒステリーになったりして
お母さんだけ問題じゃないでしょうに
泣く子供の立場から見れば
泣くことっていうのはものすごい体力消費消耗しますよ
大変です だから本人が泣いて泣いて言ってるは言ってる
なんでわかってくれないのかと
だからそういうすごい不便を我々は経験していたんです
まあ今もないわけじゃないでしょうね
大人になっても自分が言ってるんだけど
なかなかもう理解してくれないという
わかってくれないというね
まあ大人の場合はもうもう無知自慢だから心を閉鎖するでしょ
自分の意見は決まったんだから
それ以上は聞きませんよとかね
で 例えば日本の社会 政治
世界とか見てみると いろんな人々はもう一致団結しましたと
一方的に相手のはもう話も聞きませんよと
えらい文化人やと思ってるんですね
それでなんとか島の人々はみんな反対する
だから政府と話しませんよ
反対であろうが何であろうが勝手にしろよと言いたいんだけど
話し合いなさいよと まずいろんな意見をね
それは断固断ると で まあもう自分の国でもそういう苦い経験がありましたからね
テロリストがいて あの
もう話し合いは断固断ると
するとヨーロッパの連中はもう話し合いに来ないんだから
あの連中の言う分は聞いてあげなさいと
で まあそれはダメっていうことで潰ってしまったんですね
それからもう今黙ってます
みんな だからまあ話し合いは大人はしないということになっちゃいますから
なかなかコミュニケーション成り立ちません
子供はそんなことはしているわけじゃないんです
子供は言いたいんですね
言ってはいるんだけど
なかなか理解してくれない
はい その過程でお母さんが言葉を 1つ
2つとかね まあ教えてあげたりはします
それから互いに理解できる気分になるのです
それでどんどんどんどんたくさん言葉が学ぶんです
そこでお母さんも子供のことをよく理解できたと
子供もお母さんに理解できてるんだと
そういう気分になるんです
この気分ですよ 言葉は
理解できたわけじゃないんです
はい それからまあ まずリハーサルということ
まあ一応赤ちゃんからいきなり大人になってください
まああの もう結構もう学校にも学校を卒業して
もう結構言葉があるということに
はい それから我々はリハーサルするんですね
他人としゃべる前に 人は誰でもまずリハーサルするんです
誰でもやってます 少年は発音の繰り返しというリハーサルが多いんですね
ちっちゃな子供っていうのは
まあ言葉をずっとお迎えして繰り返してるんですね
何か新しい言葉を一つ覚えちゃうと
何にでもそれを使うんです
合ってるか合ってないかは関係ないんです
まあでも大人は別ですからね
外国語を学ぶとき 大人も同じことをしなくちゃいけないんですね
もし大人が外国語を学びたいと思うならば
あのちっちゃな子供がやっていることをやらなくちゃいけないんです
もう何でもいいんだから
いくら恥ずかしくても気にもしないで
覚えた単語を繰り返し使わなくちゃいけないんです
皆さんはもしかすると経験あるかもしれませんけど
日本に来て初めて日本語を学ぶ人々がまだ喋れませんね
それでも皆様と日本語で喋ってるでしょ
まあ恥ずかしくて聞いていられないんですね
で 相手が何のことなく
もうこれは言葉失礼か本当に言っていいのかさっぱりわからない
とにかく学んだことを喋る
それで結局はできるようになりますよ
それはもともと喋ってる人々にとっては
なんかすごく気持ち悪くなったり
鳥肌が立ったりする可能性はありますけど
相手はそんなことはもう知らない
外国語を学ぶ人は 皆様にしても
何かの外国語を学びたければ
まあずっと繰り返し言わなくちゃいけない
ドイツ語を学ぼうと思って
最初に Auf Wiedersehen という言葉を覚えたならば
どんな人にもそれを言わなくちゃいけないでしょう
そうすると それを習ってしまうでしょうね
そうすると ドイツ語わかる人は首をかしげますけどね
これはまあ また会いましょうって意味だから
人に会った瞬間に じゃあまた会いましょうって言うと
もう恥ずかしいでしょうね
でも相手がこの人はドイツ語はわからないんだとわかって
わかってるようになってくると
実はね それは別れる時使う言葉だよと
あ そうか じゃあこれからということで
本人がもう単語は慣れているし
それから別れるときは Auf Wiedersehen というでしょうね
そういう風に外国語を学ぶときも
私たちは赤ちゃんのやり方で学ばないと
で うまくいかないんですね
余計なことを言ったってもね
しかし 本当のリハーサルは頭の中で行いますではなくて
我々は本当にこの言葉のリハーサルはスーッと頭の中で行っているんです
それが死ぬまで続きます
死ぬまで我々は頭の中で
このトレーニングをやっています
相手とどのように喋ればよろしいかと
ずっとやっています この世間話をする時でもやっていますよ
おじいさんと孫がいろいろ喋って対話しながらカルタゲームをやっているとしても
おじいちゃんが言う言葉は先にちゃんとトレーニングとして
それから喋っているんです
小さな子供はあんまり小学生まではね
そのまま喋れますよ しかし
感じたことがありますかね
言葉の迫力はどちらにありますかというと
子供の言葉にすごい迫力があるでしょう
何も考えないで言いたいことをそのまま言っちゃうでしょ
人の前で言ってはいけないこととかね
そんなことはどうでもいいんです
もう言っちゃいます 本当に元気な子供がいるお母さんっていうのはね
大変だと思いますよ おしゃべりな子供だったらね
で 逆にもうおしゃべりの子供というのはものすごく可愛いし
もう喋るは喋るは喋るはもう
もう電車に新幹線に乗ったって
もう車両一つ全部もう自分の声で埋め尽くるんだだからね
でも真面目に聞くと あら
これなんだこれ？って感じのことも言うんです
ちょっとそんなこと言うなよとかね
言いたくはなるんだけど
子供は言うんです あの
リハーサルしないんですね
リハーサルしないで喋る
しかし それは大人が困っても
まあそんなことで社会問題が起きたわけでもないし
子供が変なことを言ったんだからといってね
かえって信頼してしまいますよ
あれは子供の言葉だから
じゃあまあそんなことはあんた相手にそんな真剣にする
子供の言葉でしょう ではないんです
だからリハーサルしなくても迫力があるんです
説得力があるんです 無視できないんです
大人の場合はもうそんなことないんです
まあ一応リハーサルして喋ってるんだからね
例えば結婚申し込みの時でも
まあ男は結構リハーサルしますよ
どんな言葉に向こうはもう感動するのかどうかね
だから意味がないんです
結局は はい とにかく覚えておいてください
我々は死ぬまで喋る リハーサルはしているんです
止まらないリハーサル
相手と話す必要があってもなくても
相手と話す気持ちがなくても
話す気持ちもないし 話す必要もない
なくても 黙っているつもりでいても
相手の話を聞くだけにすることにしても
今度は話を聞くだけにするそうと相槌もしませんよと決めても
頭の中で喋っているんです
それは止まらないんです
時々お互いもう話さないということにします
はい 話さないことにしましたと
はい 黙ってますと 本当に黙ってますけど
黙ってないんですね 頭の中で喋ってるんです
その人と訓練しているんです
心の中で喋ることはやみつきになっているんです
それで私たちにはもう余計な病気がかかっているんです
これ やみつきになっているんです
やめられないんです 本当はそんなはずではなかったんです
言葉っていうのは コミュニケーションのために後で作った道具なんです
初めは言葉ありきっていうのは
もうもうもう天地違いの嘘
嘘なんです 何の言葉にはそんなに大事な意味も何もないんです
超能力は全く 0 なんです
言葉には この呪文とかは
まあ脳細胞を摘出しているならばやってもいいんですけど
ほんのちょっとでも脳細胞あるならばやるもんじゃないんです
あんなのは全くの意味がないんです
言葉は我々はもう足が弱いと杖をつかっているような感じで
ちょっとした道具なんですね
だから子供は喋った方がお母さんが楽なんです
だから子供に言葉を教えているんです
子供にご飯を食べさせると
まあもう一応子供がそこは気に入っているならば
それを表現したいんですね
それで手を 手足やらバタバタバタバタやっちゃいますから
それでご飯食べられなくなっちゃう
なくなっちゃうんですね
また自分でスプーン引っ張ったりして
これもうもうドカンと捨てたりとかね
あれ 美味しいっていうことを表現できないんですね
それでお母さんが美味しい
美味しい 美味しいとか
何回何回も繰り返して言っちゃうと
子供はそこ覚えちゃうんですね
それを覚えたら 手足でバタバタやることをやめちゃいます
そういうことで この表現するために
コミュニケーションするために使った道具なんですよ
やがてこれもうやみつきになっちゃって
もうコミュニケーションしようがしないか関係なく
頭の中で喋ってるんですね
これが大きな問題なんです
だから頭の中で喋ってることが悪いではないんです
我々はいつでもリハーサルしてから喋るんです
その方がいいんです 特に教育の場合ではね
ただ喋っただけではね
まあ子供たちは理解してくれませんし
授業なんかではね どのように喋るべきかということがね
よくリハーサルしなくちゃいけないんですね
アメリカのお偉い方々はもうかなりリハーサルしてから喋りますからね
やる仕事もないし まあだからもう世界に向けてテレビで発表しますからね
これ結構もうすごい一流の文章を書ける人々は文章を書いてくれるし
そこはもう秒単位で計算して
読み上げてみて リハーサルして
まあ世に出て喋るんですね
だからすごい上手ですね
話は とか 私たちは舞い上がりますけど
もう結構リハーサルしてくることなんですよ
それリハーサルはいいんだけど
何か仕事ですからね 私たちは人と喋る計画もないのに
頭で喋ってるんです 会社からね
もう家に戻りましたと
一人で生活しているならば
誰とも喋る必要はないでしょう
でも喋ってるんです なんか動物でも飼った方がいいんです
一人で喋るよりは もう猫と犬と喋った方がいいんです
私は動物と よく喋ります
で 人間の喋りよりもいろんな難しいことを喋るんです
で それで気持ちはいいんで
相手がわかってないのは当たり前ですけど
で 時々みんなに笑われたことも結構ありましたけど
まあそれでも私は気にしないで喋ります
まあ国ではね まああれもうご飯くれ
あれを要求すると あのね
あんたらとは一方的にご飯くれと言ってもね
分かってないんですかね
今もうすごく材料は値段高いんだと
肉魚はもう買えないぐらい値段高いんだよ
だからキャベツとご飯食べなさいよと
なんで私が食べてるの？あんた食べられないんですかね？そんなわがまま言っていいのかい？いろいろ言うんですよ
で それでみんなもうこいつはちょっと頭がイカれてるんだと言われますけど
私は別に意味があるんだから
人と喋るよりはやっぱりあるいは自分の頭の中で余計なことを考えるよりは
その方が楽なんです というわけで
私たちはもう喋る相手がなくても
喋る計画がなくても 喋る気持ちがなくても
もうこれやみつきになっちゃって
頭の中で喋るんですね
この無口な人っていますね
あれ 結構頭の中で喋ってるんです
あまりにも喋ってるんだから
もう口で喋れないんですね
それから本番で失敗する
で 一生リハーサルしますよ
一生リハーサルするんだけど
本番になってくると失敗する
あの これ こういう例でちょっと難しいんですけど
考えてください 家に帰る
意味わかりますか？わかってると思ってるでしょ
家に帰るっていうこと
これちゃんとした文章ですけど
まあ主語は取ってますけどね
どちらでも私はでも あの人はでもどうでもいいんです
主語は家に帰る わかる気がするが
それぞれの人の頭の中のイメージが違います
問題はそれなんです 家に帰ると言ったら
あ そうと言いますよ でも
相手が家と言った時のイメージと
私が家と言った時のイメージっていうのは断然違うでしょうに
それぞれ人の家が違うでしょうに
家の状況も違うでしょうに
例えば家の家はもう借金で手を出しちゃって
もう 1 日 3回ぐらい借金取り立てが来る家だったら
まあなんとか要求 じゃあ私は家に帰るそうと
あ そう じゃあはい どうぞと言うでしょうね
で その人のイメージと
まあ結婚して子供が生まれて
子供はもうちょっと もう 1歳過ぎて
もう遊び盛りで お父さん来るまで待ってると
それでそのお父さんが
じゃあ私も家に帰るぞと言うと
その人のイメージはなんですかね
ただいまって子供が飛んでくるでしょうね
それでもうカバンも持ったまんまで
子供を抱っこしたりして
パパが帰ったそうとか言ったりとかね
前の人が 借金取り立ているんでしょうかないでしょう
周りをよく見て 裏口からこそっと入らなくちゃいけないんでしょ
だから家に帰るという
とってもシンプルな日本語なんですけど
コミュニケーション取ってるのかと
だから結局は我々はリハーサルやってますけど
本番はもう人に喋る時なんですね
その時 コミュニケーション成り立ってないんです
家に帰る程度の言葉さえもコミュニケーション成り立ってないんですから
他どう言えばいいんですかね
大変ですよ それわかってくると
もう喋ることは本当に苦痛になって嫌になるんです
もう例えばね 相手の気持ちもなんとなく別な方法でね
言葉ではなくて 別な方法で相手の心の波動を読み取れるようになってくると
まあ苦痛なんですね 喋るのは
これは何ですか？と聞くだけでもあっち来なさいと言いたくなるんです
もう時間の無駄 そういうわけで
あの 面白いでしょう 言葉を使ったのはコミュニケーションのためが最後にどうなったかというと
コミュニケーションができなくなってるんです
普通名詞を使う場合はよく起こる出来事です
あれ コモンナウンスというね
まあ普通名詞いっぱいあるでしょ？いつでもそれ起こるんです
家っていうのはコモン普通名詞なんです
で 私は誰？どなたか質問をします
まあもう仮定の話で メモはなんで書いてるんでしょうかと
なんでではなくて 何で書いてますか？と言ったら
相手がボールペンですと答える
皆様に聞こえますね わかるでしょ
意味は あの人がボールペンでメモってるんだと
ボールペンとは普通名詞でしょ
わからないでしょ？どんなボールペンかと
100円ショップで 6本セットで売ってるボールペンか
2万以上値札がついているボールペンか
あるいは 1,000 程度のわからないでしょ
あんたの趣味はなんですか？と
読書ですねと それでわかる
全然わからないんです
でも我々はわかったような気がしてるでしょ
それできつく聞いても
読書と言ったっても どんな本ですかと
あ あの 何でしたっけ？探検っていうんですか？探偵物語好きですよと言ったりと言ったりしましょう
いくらか意味が狭くなったでしょ
とはいっても 探偵物語って世の中で腐るほどあるんだから
またわからなくなるんです
我々は 我々の言語ではいっぱい普通名詞たくさんあるんです
むちゃくちゃあるんです
あの固有名詞の場合はそれほど問題起こりませんよ
普通の名詞の場合はもうむちゃくちゃなんです
そこで普通我々はもうわかってます
わかってます わかってます
錯覚で人類がみんな生きてるんですね
リハーサルを無限にして会話をしても
互いに完全に理解することはできません
ですから あの無限にリハーサルするんだけど
えっと 何といいますか
完全に相手を理解すること
理解してもらうことは成り立たないんです
この失敗も心の中のおしゃべりを強化します
それから失敗したんですね
本番で それからまたもうおしゃべり始まるんです
またリハーサル始まるんです
ああ言えばよかったのに
こう言えばよかったのにとかね
そういうことになります
はい 自我がおしゃべりにふけるという
自我の鎖という話が出ましたから
これからそのポイントなんです
この自我なんですね このおしゃべりにふけっているのは
認識体験で自分がいるという実感が湧くんです
あの漢字の間違いあったら言ってください
もうこう ずっともう今もう今日作りましたからね
チェックしてないんで
あの有名な言葉ありますね
我は思う 故に我がありというね
それなんですね 頭の中でおしゃべりしているんだから
自分がいるっていう風にえらいことを決めちゃうんですね
別にそれは証拠は何もないんです
はい これからあの仏教の中身にちょっと入ってみます
これはいつでも私は繰り返し
あの皆様に言っているところなんです
これはもう何百回も繰り返して言わないと
このシンプルな真理には気づかないんです
色声香味触法っていうのは六つの情報ありますね
それから感覚器官がありますね
感覚器官というのは眼耳鼻舌身意という
そちらに触れるんです
情報が感覚器官に触れる
で 感覚器官は六つで 情報は六種類です
その時 感覚が生じるんです
あの同じ言葉を繰り返しちゃいます
ややこしいんだけど 別々にABCDでもつけちゃえばわかりやすいんだけど
これできませんだからね
感覚器官に情報が触れると感覚が生まれるんです
その感覚にはパーリ語でヴェーダナーと言うんです
私が見る 私が聞く 私が嗅ぐ
私が味わっているということになるんです
それから目があるんだから目で感じるでしょ
それで私はこれどう表現します？私が見てますよ
あるいは私には見えてますよ
私か私にかどちらか入るんです
だから何か食べたら舌で味を感じますね
はい これが美味しいです
これが私においてですなんですね
私抜けて言語は成り立たないんですね
だからご飯は美味しいですということは論理的に間違いなんです
誰に誰が味わった時 美味しいというふうに言わなくちゃいけないんです
だからご飯は美味しいです
ウサギさんは言いましたと言っちゃうとわかるでしょうね
ありえない話ですからね
ウサギはもうニンジン食べてもご飯食べませんから
まあ一応食べますけど
あげたらね でます でもそれはウサギちゃんの餌ではありません
そういうわけで 私がなければ言語が成り立ちませんよ
はい だから自我があるという場合
そういう愚かな人々が言葉が先にあったんだよと言わなくちゃいけないんです
どうしても自我があると言いたいんですね
証拠があってもなくても
もう判決は出ているんです
だから証拠を あの 何といいますか
歪曲するんですね 現実を無視するんですね
実際そうではなくて 言語は後から生まれたんです
言語が勝手にあるく出したところで自我が生まれたんです
だから実際に自我があるわけじゃないでしょうに
実際に言語もないんだから
どんな言語でも大丈夫でしょ
みんな許可してくれれば
これにマイクロフォンと言わなくてもいいんです
あの音声受信機といえば別にいいでしょうに
だから言葉っていうのはいくらでも変えられますよ
実際 人間はすっと言葉を変えて変えていくでしょうに
結構たくさん言葉が死んで使わないことになったりもするし
新しい言葉をどんどん作ったりもするし
で そういうわけで 言葉は本来あるものじゃないんです
太陽が初めからあったんですけど
私たちはそれに太陽と名付けただけなんです
もし名前 ラベル ラベル変えましょうか
太陽にお月様と言って
お月様に太陽と言いましょうか
それで何か変なことに起こる
変なことが起こる 何も起こりませんよ
それから日本人がお釈迦様と言ったら
もう昼 空にあるものを意味するし
太陽と言えば夜空にあるものは思うだけの話でしょうに
だから人間が言葉が言葉から自我を作ったんです
だからあまりにもおかしいんです
それが いまだに言葉にすごい意味があると思っているんです
超能力というか 魔力があると思っているんですね
本当は何が起こることも
この体の中で感じるんでしょうね
目耳鼻で この感じることで私が見て
私が聞いて 私が感じた
私は痛い 私は悲しい 私は楽しいと言っちゃうんです
それは言語上必要ですからね
主語は まあ日本では曖昧で喋れますけど
例えば英語ならしっかり締まってないとね
主語がないと 主語と動詞がないと
もうどうにもならん 例えば日本語で降ってますね
今は言えるでしょ 主語がないんですね
でもわかるでしょ 英語ではレーニンだけでは何もわかりませんね
やっぱりイットイズ必要なんです
だからまあ主語が言語には必要なんです
感覚は苦楽 不苦不楽という 3つになるんです
感覚は 3種類というよりも
情報が触れると生まれる感覚は 3種類になります
一つは楽 音楽なんか聴覚でしょ？耳で感じるでしょ
で 楽な感覚が生まれると音楽とレッテルを貼るんです
あ 苦しい感覚が生まれてくると
別な何か名前をするんです
あれってすごい失礼なんです
音のせいじゃないでしょうに
私の勝手でしょうに 私
すごい気分いい 私が気分良ければ
あんた本当に素晴らしい歌手でしょ？音楽は上手ですね
感動しましたとかね 自分が気に入らなかったら
相手はプロであっても
あれは面白くないねとかね
あの人あの下手ですねとかね
すごい その人を下手と言える？自分の感覚のことでしょうに
だからそのとんでもない罪でしょうに
それが 我々はもう人のせいにするんです
あの舞台は面白くなかった
みんなもう大ヘタクソで
もう嫌ですねとかね そのグループは下手か上手かっていうのはわかったもんじゃなくないんですよ
ね 舞台を見た私の感覚は良くなかったんです
それが他人に当ててやろうと思っているんです
そんなすごいもう恐ろしいことをするのは
この自我なんですね それに合わせて怒り
欲 痴 無知ですね の感情
煩悩が生じるんです はい
ちょっと真剣に考えてください
六根がありますよ もう捨てられませんね
これが目捨てられません
耳もセットに生まれつきついていますからね
どうにもならん それで体ができているんです
六根で その六根は情報を感じるんですね
感じると感覚が生まれるんです
この感覚は楽か苦か 不苦不楽どちらかなんです
楽しいかつまらない 楽しいか嫌か
つまらないかなんです
常にそれを感じていますよ
楽しい感覚はつまらない
嫌な感覚とかね いつでも感じているんです
それに合わせて心の中で貪瞋痴が生まれるんです
煩悩が生まれて心が汚れるんです
そこでこの感覚に ラベルを貼るんですよ
言葉という 存在に対する執着がそれから生じるんです
貪瞋痴が生まれたら もうもうもうすごい
もう嫌な状況なんです
そこでもうどうにかして
どうにかして これ直して
これ直して いい方向へ持っていかなくちゃいけない
これはあかんやという気分で
執着という この生きる衝動
生きる欲が生まれてくるんです
どうしても生きてみたいという
煩悩のウイルス 自我の病という
ウイルスはまき散らすべきものです
それには賛成でしょ そうしないと存続できません
だってかわいそうですよね
ウイルスはどちらかに入って感染しなきゃウイルスが死んじゃうでしょうに
だからウイルスのために考えるならば
撒き散らした方がいいんです
人は感情 煩悩というウイルスを他人に撒き散らしたくなるんです
それはなんで悪くないんですかね
だって自分の貪瞋痴の感情を他人に撒き散らしたいんですよ
しゃべらしにいられないだから
しゃべらしにいられない
興奮に落ちる 陥る 意味わかりますかね？やっぱりウイルスは撒き散らすべきでしょ
それに反対ならば 今や何やってますかね？自分がなんとか感情が生まれてくると
ねぇねぇねぇ もう聞いてよ
聞いてよとか 聞きたくないんだけど
携帯で電話したり メールを送ったり
テキストしたり あれ 日本語でテキストって言うんですか？まあショートメッセージとかね
SMS とかね まあいろいろ携帯用語あります
一番だらしない言葉はテキストなんです
テキスト まあテキストということで
テキストメッセージということで
で 皆様メールという言葉でしょうね
携帯でメールを送ったり
あれ ウイルス撒き散らしてるでしょうに
どこかに行って何か食っちゃえば
もう写真を撮って 携帯で今これ食べてます
これ超美味しいんだよとかね
先着 50名様しかこの料理作れませんだけど
うまく自分入りましたよとかね
先着 50名と言ったっても
100名行ったってもあり得ますけどね
私も一回もうあの 食べる時間に時間になってきて
もう見たら見たらもうもうちょっとした店があって
あんまり入りたくなかったんですけど
なんとか食べ物はあるんですね
やっぱり先着 15名かな
私は行って おそらくこれないでしょうと
えっ ありますよ じゃあこれお願いしますと
ああ そういうことかいと
どうしても私は並んでいないし
だから先着 10名の中には入れませんと思いますけど
まあそれはどうでもいいんですけど
そうやって自分の興奮
自分の煩悩をとにかく撒き散らす
気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
人の話をそのまま聞いたらあかん
よく調べた方が この人はどんな感情
どんな主観 どんな恨み
我々に押し付けようとしているのかと
特にこのニュースやらね
マスコミの喋りっていうのは
政治評論とかあるでしょうに
現代社会状況を分析して喋るとかね
ちゃんと社会状況を分析しているのか
自分の感情 好みをまき散らしているのかと
その区別だけを私はしますよ
あの 客観的なデータならもうはい
わかりました 助かりましたと
自分の主観的なダラダラははい
さようなら それはと いうことにしますけど
で 私たちはどうしても喋りたいんでしょうに
どうしても喋りたいことは
この自分の煩悩というウイルスをどうしてもまき散らしたいんです
だから自殺するバカも仲間はインターネットで呼びうんですよ
勝手に死ねばいいのに
何かに怒ったら もうまた仲間を探して探して仲間を強引にする
あんたも賛成参加してくださいとかね
あのタイランドではね
もう怒り憎しみがまき散らしちゃって
もう国がもう政治できない状態になっているでしょうに
国が全体的に恐ろしい経済ダメージを受けているのに
一向に構わないんですね
自分たちの怒り 憎しみ
もう全体的にまき散らしちゃえばいいと
で 平気で国の財産壊したり
まあいくらか仏教の国だから
いくらか他の国々と比較すると
まあまともな国なんですけど
あんまり派手じゃなくておとなしいし
なのにあの様なんですね
それでもやっぱり人っていうのは
自分の煩悩 汚れまき散らしたいんです
その方法っていうのは喋ることなんです
それで心の中でおしゃべりのボリューが起こるんです
で 心に怒りが出てくると
頭の中でものすごくボルーのように激しい流れのように言葉がおしゃべりの輪が生まれるんです
欲が生まれてくると まあ言葉のおしゃべりの輪がまたもう猛速度で回転するんです
これでいても立ってもいられなくなっちゃうと
みんなにね ね 聞いて聞いてとかね
聞いたってもわからない
あまりにも興奮しすぎちゃって
あれはね すごいです すごいって何の意味もないでしょうに
皆様の言語 大体そんなことで
あれって超面白い すごいんですよとかね
あれ 何ですかね で 何の意味もない言葉っていうのは結構言語にあるんですね
その一部を機会があれば他人に言う
それで頭の中でボルーのように感情が回転するわ
回転するわ 機会があったら相手に一部を言う
全部言わないんです そこでも自我が言ってる
言うべきことと言ってはいけないことっていうのも分け分けるんです
道徳的判断じゃないんです
自分の自我 エゴを応援する
守るために 応援するために必要なものだけを言う
エゴにダメージ与えるものが感情あってもと言わない
例えば成功したらもういいプラスですけど
失敗したらもう黙ってるとかね
失敗したんだそうとは言わないんですね
勝ったら万々歳 勝ったそう勝ったそう
お母ちゃん勝ったそうとかね
死んでるんだけどね もうそれでも言うんですね
で 負けたらお母ちゃん負けたよと言わないんですね
で それ言っちゃうと自我が傷つきますからね
本当に人間のやり方ってのは聞いてないんですよ
そんなにカッコいいおしゃべりってわけじゃないんです
もうこの人を楽しませる芸能の世界でも
もう本当に喋る そこはすごくなんか期待してますね
で 口下手はダメなんですね
芸能人としては で 歌手であっても
もう漫才師のように面白く喋れなくちゃいけない
だからどうでもいいだらしないことはダラダラ喋ってます
で おしゃべり上手でない芸能人っていうのはなかなかもう人気がなくなっちゃうんですね
このいろいろね 講演会とかある場合でも
やっぱり喋りが なんかそちらの方が優先みたいんで
行ったことはないんだけどね
まあかなり前暇があった時はまああの何回も行ったこともありますけど
で まあ面白くなかったんですね
おしゃべりはね まあわからないし
何言ってるのかと まあ有名人のね
何人かのね もう音楽とかなんとか聞こうといってね
で 音楽はまあまあプロだからね
まあそれはそれで問題はないんだけど
まあ戦争の話とかね そんなことを言っても
まあとにかくこのおしゃべりが欲しいみたいですね
世の中では で それであの感情ですね
我々は笑いたいし 楽しみたいし
大変でしたね 波乱万丈の人生でしょうねとかね
相手のことを心配したりとか
それでも頑張ってうまくなったなよとか
いろいろ感情を作りたいんですね
その人の心もさらに煩悩にそれから汚れるんです
それで自分の心に嫉妬
怒りが生まれると もう興奮しちゃって
とにかく喋る 喋ると相手の心にもこのヴィレスが感染するし
煩悩とヴィレスが で 自分ももう喋っちゃったんだから
自分の心もさらに同じヴィレスでまた強化してしまうんですね
いわゆる聞いた人の心も汚れますって意味なんです
聞いた人を汚すと 自分もさらに汚れているんです
あの煩悩っていうのは
一旦人にあげたらなくなるんだったらありがたいんで
それは金だけなんですよ
で 人に怒りあげると自分の怒り消えませんね
増えるんですね 他人に対して怒ると
怒って発散しちまった
私は清々しまったってことじゃないんです
逆に自分がさらに怒るんですね
なんとかしてそこを金に回ってくれればね
変えてくれれば なんとか頑張ってください
もう金なら使えば使うほど増えるならばね
しかし この怒り 欲などなど
煩悩がその方式でやってます
使えば使うほど増えるという
で 不可能な共感 私たちは他人の気持ちを理解したいし
共感もしたいのです しかし
無理です 他人の気持ちは共感したいでしょうね
できない 人の心の中で
噴火している煩悩 感情はそのまま聞く相手の心に生じません
また別なポイントなんです
私たちの心の中 噴火状態なんです
貪瞋痴が噴火しています
それで喋りますが 同じ噴火が起こるということは限ってないんです
何が起こるんです しかし
同じものでもないんです
なぜかというと コミュニケーションが成り立たないんです
言葉っていうのはもう極限に主観なんです
家といったら 人はそれぞれの家を思うんであって
共通的な家を思わないんです
標準的な家ということはないんです
ボールペンといったら
自分勝手に知ってるボールペンのことを思い浮かぶんであって
ボールペン標準というのはないんです
そういうわけだからね
言葉って無理ですね 言葉で喋るのは
はい それで人は勝手に感情を引き起こすんだから
私は怒りで噴火していて喋るとしましょう
しかし 必ずしも相手も怒りで噴火するということは定かじゃない
ちょっとした例を出していると思います
個人の主観 感情 妄想によって変わります
その個人の状況によってこれ変わるんです
まだ難しいんですね 人がもうギャーギャー怒って喋っていても
自分の精神状態によって自分も一緒に怒るか
無視するか 笑うか どうにか自分の態度なんです
釣りに誘われたら殺生は嫌だという人もいるでしょ
その例でわかるでしょう
釣りに行こうよという人は楽しみたいでしょ
相手が私は殺生は嫌です
そこで言葉を喋りました
相手に欲を作りたかったんですね
釣りに行こうよ もうゴールデンウィークでもあるし
いっぱい釣った方がいいんじゃない？とかね
楽しいんだよと 寒くもないし
言ったんだけど 相手が私は殺生は嫌いです
と言うと こちらの噴火と同じ噴火じゃないでしょ
向こうの心に起きた噴火は
だからあなたのことはそこでたまらないと相手に言っちゃうと
私もあなたのことを嫌で嫌でもう吐きが出るぐらい
気持ち悪いんだということもごく普通あり得るんです
だから そこを見てもコミュニケーションは成り立ってないんです
はい それで思考妄想っていうのはただですかと
思考妄想は無料 ただではありません
その代は 一方的に高騰するんですね
高騰って正しいかどうか分かりません
この思考妄想の代はすーっと高騰するんです
嘘だと思ってるでしょ
皆様お金払ってないでしょ
妄想するためにはお金より高いものを払っているんです
思考妄想するたびに 貪瞋痴の煩悩が溜まるんです
思考妄想するはするほど
こちらで貪瞋痴が溜まるんですよ
貪瞋痴っていうのは借金なんです
人間は幸福になりたいんです
これ 借金だらけでは幸福になっ
幸福になりません サンカーラというものが生まれるんです
これは行も業でも同じものです
サンカーラという衝動が強くなる
いわゆる業が生まれるんです
悪業アクサラカンマ 必ず増えるという意味です
それで思考妄想するたびに
我々の悪業の数字がどんどん上がっちゃうんです
恐ろしいスピードで上がるんです
借金ばっかり増えるんです
全く幸福になることっていうのは
もう夢見ることもできなくなるんです
悪業増えるということは
善業がもうなくなっていますよ
だから決して妄想はただではありません
幸福に生きることをもう捨てなくちゃいけないんです
これ 金より大事でしょうに
幸福に楽しみに生きることがもう価値つけられないぐらい高い高価なものでしょうに
これ捨ててますよ だから
思考妄想はただではありません
自分が不幸に陥ることで
自己破壊することでその代を払うんです
だから我々はどんどんどんどんどんどん不幸になっていく
社会は破壊していく いろんなものは崩壊していく
自然も崩壊していく もう道徳的な知識も何でもかんでも
もう堕落 堕落 堕落とかね
まあ社会全体的に喋るのはあまり意味がないんですけど
まあやはり個人個人で見てみると
やっぱりもう堕落していくというのが結構ある現象ですね
彼らがもう払ってます
思考の代価は はい 妄想の舞台
頭の心の中は舞台です
これはこのポイントだけでも覚えておいてください
役に立ちます あの 我々の頭の中が舞台なんです
自分が主人公の役を演じるんです
頭の中は舞台劇場で 主人公の役は自分が演じるんです
自分の感情 煩悩に適した物語を作って
頭の中で舞台公演を行うんです
どんな人の頭の中でも
舞台劇場で何か物語を演じている
演出しているんです 自分が主人公なんです
ストーリーはそれぞれ
これって大変な危険なことなんです
例えば 嫉妬で悩んでいる人は
嫉妬が出てくる物語を作って
ドラマを作って 頭の中で演じているんです
他の役は全部頭の中で作るんです
もう欲は強い人が 若者とかね
頭の中で欲のドラマを作るんですね
作ってそれを演じるんです
だから我々は この病んでいる心の状態に合わせて台本作って
ストーリーを作って そこを演じるんですね
演じるとどうなるんですかね
蘇るでしょ 演じるということは
だから舞台でシェイクスピアのオセロを見たとしましょう
もう200年ぐらい昔のあの人がね
考え出した世界がもう現代蘇ってくるでしょ
だから私たちの頭の中で
いつでも自分が主人公にして
悲劇か喜劇か もう恐ろしい劇か何かも作っているんです
そこで演じるんです だから
おしゃべりっていうのはかなり大変な危険なものなんです
自分の欲 怒り 落ち込み
憎しみ 恨み 劣等感 優越感
無知 邪見などが拡大していきます
邪見もそうですよ 何か変な新興宗教にでも入っちゃうと
もうそれからもう舞台劇場して
もう自分の邪見を固めていくんです
自主行為で自分が不幸に陥るんです
だから 自分が台本を書いて
自分がディレクティング監督をやって
自分が主人公で演出して
自分が不幸になるんです
この頭の中のドラマという言葉だけは覚えておいてください
これで結構人はダメになるんです
しかし 思考は止まれない
そんなこと言っても止まれないんです
思考妄想は危険だとわかっても
止まること 止めることはできないんです
感情の衝動ではなくても
他人と話さなくてはいけないんですね
例えば 私が今言った病気がない
心に感情がない 煩悩がない
とは言っても 人と喋らなくちゃいけないでしょ
怒り 怒り 嫉妬 落ち込み
憎しみがなくても 何も思わなくても
人と喋らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
その分はやっぱりリハーサルしないと
自分自身でも頭の中で物事の整理をしなくてはいけないんです
もう一つ大事なおしゃべりがあるんです
我々は喋りながら 頭で自分が学んだこと
やるべきこと やるべき順番
頭の中で整理整頓するんです
だから思考は必要なんです
このおしゃべりは今まで悪いところばっかり言いましたけど
何か勉強したところで
自分で喋ってみると いわゆる頭の中でよく覚えられるし
理解もできるんです で
私もだいたい若い頃はいくらか現金でしたから
物は覚えられて覚えられる時期がありましたけどね
今何でも忘れる時期になってますからね
で その覚えられる時期ではだいたい一回で覚えるんです
大学でもどんな授業でも
どんな内容でも 一回ではもうメモはないんです
本も一回で である工夫があったんです
おしゃべりの工夫なんです
私はその人と喋っているんです
本を読みながら 結構厳しい
好き勝手な喋りだからね
好き勝手なもう で 喋って喋りながら読んでいるんです
だから本を読むともう覚えているんです
あるいは対話にならないもの
発表しなくちゃいけないものがあるんですね
で 発表があって 今研究している
その時は研究するための資料を読みながらも発表もしているんです
頭の中で それでも一回でもう覚えているし
文章を書く場合も なんのことなくさらっと書けちゃいますね
もうできているんです
瞬間で だからあの 結構有効に使えるいいものでもあります
おしゃべりは ですから
言葉の制御 仏教では清浄語と呼ぶんですね
思考の管理 清浄思惟と言うんですね
正しい思考 断然的に必要です
で おしゃべりのとんでもない悪いところも説明しました
自己破壊に陥るところも説明しました
しかし おしゃべりなく
我々にはちょっと困りますよ
人間社会で生きているんだから
人とこんにちはと言わなくちゃいけないし
ね おはようと言わなくちゃいけないし
で そういうことだから
やっぱりおしゃべりもしなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 私たちはおしゃべり禁止ではなくて
思考の制御 どんな思考をした方がよろしいなのかと
そこを制御するんですね
そうすると 自己破壊になるおしゃべりはカットして
自分を幸福になるおしゃべりにする
あの正思惟っていうのはそういうことなんです
不幸になる思考をやめて
幸福になる思考をすると 4つあります
それから喋る場合も 発表する場合でも正語なんですね
何でも喋るんじゃなくて
自我で管理しません 幸福で管理するんです
これは言っちゃうと 私も不幸になる
相手も不幸になるんだから言わないと
これ言った方が私も幸福
相手も幸福だから喋るというところで言葉に管理します
えーと もう思っているより時間経ってます
ちょっと一旦消します
はい 始まります それから経典に入っている仏教のこの沈黙について話してみたいと思います
ムニという言葉がございまして
パーリ語でもインドのよく使う言葉です
で 漢文でないんだから
そのままムニと書いています
これは意味は仙人聖者ということなんですね
ムニに沈黙行者という意味があります
まあ原文ではね 普通ムニというのは仙人なんですけど
言葉の意味は沈黙行者なんです
釈尊がその定義を変えて
黙ることではムニにならないという立場を取られたんです
インド人がそう思っていたんです
聖者は喋りませんよと
お釈迦様は怒って喋らないだけでは聖者にならんぞと
他人と語らない 会話をしないことで
ムニ 行者 仙人 グルになれるならば簡単なことです
実際 現代もやってます
もうグルになりたくて
聖者になりたくて もうずっと 1年 2
年 3年とか黙ってるんです
そこでみんなもう尊敬して
いろんな食べ物やら金やら持ってきてお布施したりするんですけど
本人が喋りません すごい便利な修行です
鈍足無知な人も聖者になりますからね
そのやり方では黙っていりゃいいんだからね
まあちょっと頑張らないとね
しかしそれでもね まあ音を立ててはいけませんだからね
ムニの行はもうね といいます
これマニーと読まないで読まないでください
これパーリ語なんです
モーネイヤ モーネイヤっていうのは
ムニの行 あれ 仙人が行う行に修行にモーネイヤと言うんです
はい それから沈黙行って何なのかと入ります
モーネイヤは 3つあります
沈黙は 3つあります アンクットルネが敵にパトモーネイヤスットからティーマニビッケモーネイヤニカタマニティーニ
カーヤモーネイヤンワチモーネイヤンマノモーネイヤン
比丘たちよ 沈黙は 3つあります
その 3つとは何ですか？１
体の沈黙 ２ 言葉の沈黙 ３
心の沈黙です 比丘たちよ
体の沈黙とは何？わかりましたね
沈黙行は これブッダの言葉
沈黙行は 3種類だよと
体の沈黙 言葉の沈黙 心の沈黙
はい これから体の沈黙って何ですか？と
大胆でしょうね 沈黙といえば喋らないだけでしょうに
仏教には体の沈黙もあります
カタマニビッケカーヤモーネイヤン
体の沈黙とは何ですか？イダビッケビクパナーディパトパティウィラトーホーティアディンナーダンナパティウィラトーホーティ
めんどくさいだからすぐに来ます
比丘たちよ 殺す 殺生から離れる
中途から離れる 祭祀することですね
性行為から離れるのです
これが体の沈黙と言います
これは出家に言ってますから
この性行為入っても入ってます
在家の場合は不邪淫ですね
不倫してはいけない それで体を沈黙させなさいと
殺生しない 盗みはしない
出家なら性行為はしないと
カタマンチャビッケワチモーネイヤン
言葉の沈黙は何ですか？イダビッケビクムサーワーダパティウィラトーホーティピスナーワーチャパティウィラトーホーティピスナーヤワーチャパティウィラトーホー
ティパルサーヤワーチャパティウィラトーホーティサンパップラパーパティウィラトーホーティイダンウッチャキビッケワチモーネイヤン
比丘が嘘つくこと 両説これは離間語とも辞書にありました
噂言うことですね それから粗悪語
あ 語は忘れちゃった 粗悪語
いわゆるきつい汚い侮辱の言葉を言わないという
まあ奇語とも言いますね
奇語もあります これは無駄話ですね
から離れるんです それが言葉の沈黙です
それで嘘を言わないこと
きつい言葉 いわゆる 暴力的な言葉
侮辱的な言葉を使わない
噂は言わない 離間語は言わない
それから無駄話を言わないと
4つ守れば言葉の沈黙なんです
難しいのは心の沈黙なんです
カタマンチャビッケマノモーネイヤ
パーリ語で読みますかね
日本語で読みましょう
比丘が煩悩をなくすことから起こる無上の真解脱栄解脱に具体的に経験し
体験し済むのです これは心の沈黙でありますと
難しいね わかりやすく言えば
解脱に達することなんです
解脱に達することが心の沈黙なんです
しかし 皆様には体の沈黙と言葉の沈黙はできます
だから ムニの仙人になる道はもう今からも歩めます
ヒンドゥ教とは違います
喋ってもいいんです 沈黙業者なんです
殺生などの罪から離れる
嘘を言うことなどの罪から離れる
それで立派なブッダに認められる
賛嘆される立派な仙人の道を歩んでいるんです
これで煩悩もなく悟ったら
もう正真正銘の仙人なんですね
解脱に達することが心の沈黙
これがポイントですね
逆に言えば 解脱に達するまで
このおしゃべりは止まりません
限りのない心のおしゃべりは
解脱に達して煩悩をなくすことで成り立つのです
ん ちょっと間違ってます
なくなるのです だから気長くして修行すればいいんです
だから仏教っていうのは無口ではないんです
黙ることは仏教的な沈黙ではありません
ただ黙っているだけではね
仏教的な沈黙ではありません
サンニパティターナンゴービッカーウェードアンカラニーヤン
ダンミーワーカタアリオワトゥンニブート
集まった時は比丘たちよ
君たちは聖なる沈黙を守るか
真理法ですね を語るかという 2つのひとつをするべきなのですと
お釈迦様がお坊さんたちが集まったら完全沈黙を守りなさいと言ってないんです
聖なる沈黙っていうのは
ずっと修行に みんな大勢お坊さんたちがいるんだけど
黙って瞑想中でいる それは聖なる沈黙
でなくて喋ります 喋る場合は
ブッダの教えについて
真理について喋るんです
いわゆる有意義なことを喋ると
だから仏教は別に沈黙行の世界ではないんです
で 思考の流れを止め止められるんです
サンユッタニカーヤ二番目
ニダーナワーガ・ビクサンユッタニ
こういうふうにあります
アリオトゥンニバハオアリオトゥンニバハオーティ
ブッチャティカタモヌコビアリオトゥンニバハオーティ
モッガラーナ尊者が語るところです
友よ 聖なる沈黙 聖なる沈黙というのは何なんでしょうかと
仏教でよく言うんですよ
アリオトゥンニバハオという言葉がよくあるんです
聖なる沈黙 目連尊者が聞くんです
友達を この聖なる沈黙
聖なる沈黙と言っているでしょう
あれって一体何なのかと
知ってますかと 言葉 思考
論理の機能を停止して
禅定から起こる喜と楽に備わった第二禅定に入ることです
難しいね 瞑想すると禅定に入ります
禅定で第一 第二 第三 第四と4つあります
これで瞑想禅定に入って
一から合格して二に達したら言葉が止まるんです
頭の中で喋ることはなくなるんです
第一禅定に入っても 頭の中で言葉を使っています
このパーリ語は下にあります
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラーナンウーパサマーという
ヴィタッカヴィチャーラというのは考えることですね
なくなってサンパサーダナンアッジャッタンサンパサーダナン
心の中ですごく柔らかな気分になってきます
思考が止まると 内がすごく
バラバラになってしまいます
それでエコーディバワー
心は統一するんです それでアヴィチャーラン
アヴィタッカ アヴィチャーラン
思考がない サマーディジャン
サマーディから生まれたピーティとスッカ
喜と楽がある あの 2番目の禅定に入ることであると
アヤンウッチティ アリヨットニバ
これが聖なる沈黙なんです
禅定に入ることなんです
その時 心のおしゃべりがやめます
止め止めます 私はこの禅定に入っていても
思考に関わる概念が心に入ってくるんですと
あの これ 私はといって私ではなくて
目連尊者なんです 目連尊者があの友達たちに言うんです
これで私は第2禅定に入りましたよと
入ってもポツンポツンと概念が
言葉に関わる概念が湧いてくるんだと
嫌なこちゃって 嫌なこっちゃってことですね
これ自分の昔話してます
今阿羅漢ですけど 今弟子たちに説法しているところですけど
やっぱり自分の修行の時を教えているんですね
で 私はおしゃべり止めましたよと
第2禅定で止めたんだけど
湧いてくるんだと あっちこっちで
その時釈尊がこう言うんです
モッガッラーナ モッガッラーナ マー бラーマナ アリヤン トゥンニー バワン パマード アリエ トゥンニー バハ
ウェ チッタン サンター ペーティ ペーヒ アリエ トゥンニ バハウェ チッタン エコーディ バワーン カローティ
カローヒ アリエ トゥンニ バハウェ チッタン サマーダハーティ
これで瞑想がなんとなくうまくいかなくなったところで見て
お釈迦様がビシッと叱責するんです
これすっごく優しいというか
厳しい言葉でモッガラーナという意味なんです
モッガラーナ あんた何やっているのか
という感じなんです 意味はモッガラーナよ
バラモンよ 聖なる沈黙に対して怠ってはならない
軽く見るなよと しっかり真剣に聖なる沈黙を守りなさいと
ちょっと軽く見ちゃったんですね
楽ちんやと それで言葉がまた湧き上がってきたんですね
お釈迦様叱ったんです
軽く見るなよと しっかりと集中して
聖なる沈黙を保ちなさいと
静寂 沈黙に心を統一しなさい
静寂沈黙の禅定に入りなさいと
だからもう仏教ではこの繰り返し禅定に入るという教えがありまして
一旦禅定を作ったら はい
吾輩は最終解脱したと言ってね
人殺しにはいかないで
何回何回 何回何回 繰り返し繰り返しそこに入ってしっかりするんです
私はご指導通りに静寂沈黙の禅定に達したのですと
こちらで言っているのは
本当は悟り開いたって意味なんです
第2禅定のことじゃないんです
ここは微妙なんです 一般の方々にはそこら辺は読めないと思います
経典読んでも 微妙に裏があります
で 第2禅定に入っても
誰でもある時期  10分
30分とか思考なしでいられます
が パッと上がってくるんです
おしゃべりは で 悟りに達したらその問題はないんです
だからお釈迦様が聖なる沈黙ということで厳しく言ったんですね
そのおっしゃったのは解脱のことなんです
禅定のことじゃないんです
それで目連尊者が成功しました
釈尊に認められた大慧者である
正しく言うならば 大慧者であると正しく言うならば
それが私に当てはめる言葉なのですと自慢しますね
目連尊者はお釈迦様に認定された大慧者といえば
俺のことだよと 目連尊者言うんです
ということは 完全たる悟りに達して
お釈迦様が認めたということになります
この経典では 第2の禅定に達することと
思考妄想の流れが止まることになるのです
達すると だから私たちにも瞑想して思考なくなったらどんなもんかいと経験したければできますけどもね
しかし そんな軽い経験じゃないんです
あの ちょっと長く修行して
瞑想して 瞑想に慣れて慣れきっちゃって
経験積み重ねないと あんまりちょっと把握できなくなると思います
これ かなりの大胆な経験なんです
思考なくなるということが
しかし これは言語の死なんですね
第二専行に入ると言語がストップするんです
言葉の死なんです ストップなんです
また難しいことを言わなくちゃいけなくなりました
この想 サンニャーという言葉があります
言葉のラベルを貼る前に
心に概念 認識 知 知ることが起きているんです
よく覚えてください 言葉は後から来たものです
言葉ってなんかお嫁さんみたいですね
外から来るんだけど 結局は全部支配して我が物にしちゃうんですね
旦那さんにお前出ていけと言うんです
喧嘩するときは で 言葉っていうのは後から来たんです
最初は我々には経験があるんです
知ることしています 認識しています
概念いっぱいあるんです
しかし それ表現できないんですね
それで言葉というラベルを貼っておくんです
バラとか百合とか箸とか豆腐とか
いろいろラベルを貼っておくんです
だから このラベルの停止ではすべて停止じゃないんです
第二専行でおしゃべりは終わりますが
概念は回転しているんです
言葉がなく 概念がずっと回転しているんです
それは熱想パパンチャマンニャナというのです
熱想という単語を私はよく使ってますからね
我々はデータを熱想するんですね
必ず熱想するんです ありのままには一度も見ないんです
だから熱想する機能が想とも言えるし
サンニャーとも言えるし
パパンチャとも言うし
またパーリ語でマンニャナという言葉も使っています
熱想機能 赤ちゃんも熱想します
あのほんのちっちゃな
どうしてもくだらない
面白くない ちょっとしたおもちゃとかなんとか見てすごく喜ぶでしょ
だから相当熱想妄想してますよ
しかし 言語はないんです
言葉がないんです ヴィパッサナー実践で熱想機能を停止させると
真理が現れあらわになって煩悩が消え
解脱に達するんです それでヴィパッサナー瞑想という瞑想がありまして
そこを思考を止める瞑想なんです
これ 順番でできるように教えられてあります
最初はもう言語と戦って
しかし 悪いことに我々は言葉使って戦い合っています
あえて言葉使うんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で
このあえて言葉を使うことで
経験と言葉っていうのは
あら 何の関係もないやと発見するんです
それだけででも自我が破れる可能性はあります
世間 世間は 初めから言葉あったんだと
言葉には言霊があるんだとかね
随分ちんぷんかんぷんなんです
あれはただのラベルだろうと
これはと ボールペンにボールペンと言ったってもね
ペットボトルと言ったってもどうでもいいんです
もう正規社会 世界が破壊するわけじゃないんです
それでみんなで決めて
これからペットボトルといったらこの書くものにしましょうよと
そうなりますよ 別に ですから
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で
この言葉で我々は思考を停止する訓練をする
そうすると ちらちらとあまりも邪魔しているんだから
瞑想に真理が見えてくるんです
この見える見えるたびに心が成長して
真理が全部そのまま見えたら悟りに達します
概念の停止が本物の心のストップなんです
概念も性もサンニャーのニローダですね
悟りっていうのは はい
それから沈黙の意義 これから簡単です
非常に難しいところはありました
俗世間には心のおしゃべりは必要ということ
と はてなですね 思考して行動する
先に考えないで 頭の中で議論をしないで行為をすることが無理です
だから俗世間ではおしゃべりが必要なんです
何もできないんです 先に喋れないと
おしゃべりしている間は悟れませんよ
しかし 俗世間ではおしゃべりが必要です
一人の勝手なおしゃべりが心の中で
で 先に考えて 頭の中でいろいろ議論して
頭の中でね 議論して行動するんです
例えばキャベツ買わなくちゃと
そこらへん そこらへん
店 3軒あります 場合は頭の中で議論するんですよ
議論して じゃああの店に行きましょうと
例えば 品物のいいところで買い物をしたいと
いうと 一駅は行かなくちゃいけなくなると
安いところで買っちゃうというと
100 キロ  100 キロじゃなくて 100 メートルぐらい歩かなくちゃいけない
そんな歩く人は隣で買うと
隣のコンビニで買わなくちゃいけないと
もしかするとコンビニでキャベツはない可能性もあるし
という だから議論しています
言葉という経験に貼るラベルを組み合わせて新たな絵を描いて
それを実行するんです
だから結局我々は何をしても
講演終わったら家に帰るでしょうに
それでもやっぱり台本ができています
頭の中で いろいろ言葉のラベルがありますね
ラベルをカードを入れ替えたりするような感じで
入れ替えたりして あの
タロット占いやってるような感じで
カードを入れ替えたりするんです
頭の中でタロットやってます
やって はい この行動にするぞと
ですから 生きている上で
常識の範囲で心の中で喋ることが必要です
常識の範囲で喋ることが必要です
気をつけてください 頭の中でおしゃべり
何でもいいわけじゃないんです
常識だけにしっかりとしなくちゃいけないんです
無駄な筆使いがない 線の少ない
しかも美しい言葉の絵を心の中で描けるのでしょうかと
今もうゴミばっかりでしょ
頭の中で良くない絵を描けないんですね
子供の落書きよりも最低なんです
だから行動もそうなんですね
だからまず頭で言葉の絵を描かなくちゃいけない
美しい絵を描く場合は
線の線は少ない方が腕がいいんです
だから無数に線描いて描いて
この漫画みたいにね あれはそんな腕がいいわけじゃないんです
本当の画家はもう筆はもう二
三回しか動かしません
キャンバスの上で これでもできているんです
そのように我々も線も少ない
無駄のない作品できますかと
できたら人生は最高です
はい 言葉の絵を結作に
妄想も無駄な思考も止める訓練をする
まず妄想と無駄な思考をやめますと
訓練あります 感情を制御する
あの妄想止める訓練というのは
この慈悲の瞑想をしたり
またいろいろ念じる瞑想があります
何かね やればいいんですね
皆様は慈悲の瞑想 時間あったら慈悲の瞑想と時間あったら慈悲の瞑想すると
それで瞑想妄想がなくなるんです
みるみるうちに人生幸せになるんですよ
きれいな絵を描けます
頭の中で それから感情を制御する
感情の思考 妄想を気づいた瞬間で停止する
感情っていうのは怒り
欲ですね それは制御する
怒りに欲に負けない 怒り
欲の感情が生まれたら
さっさとその場で停止してみる
はい ストップ そういう訓練しなくちゃいけない
あの切磋切磋何 切磋琢磨って言ったけど
タイトルだ 傑作 この傑作っていうのは楽じゃないんです
修行は必要です どんな世界でも
頭に仕事がない時 慈悲喜捨の思考で心を埋め尽くす
あの経典に沿って書かなくちゃいけないんだから
慈悲喜捨の 4つも書きまったけど
普通は慈悲の瞑想で十分です
空・無常・無我という見方で世を観察する
今何が流行っているんだという
あんな汚れた角度を捨ててください
空である 無常である 無我であるという角度で
世の中ちょこちょこと観察してください
あー無常だなとかね 論理的・理性的であること
常に具体性を重んじること
日々論理的に生きてみてほしい
理性で生きていってほしい
それからくだらないことを考えない
いつでも具体的で具体的で
実践性に欠けている観念を避ける
考えたっても 観念はやめてください
観念ばっかし こうやったらいいなとかね
空を飛べばいいなとかね
宇宙旅行できればいいなと
いい加減なこと 実践性が欠けているんだったら
すべてやめた方がいいんです
私にも時々 あなたはこんなに立派な仏教だから
これは世界に広げるべきでしょうとかね
そんなことあんた考えてないんですかと
結構怒るんで その言われると私は口で笑いますけど
アホでしょうね 私一人の人間でね
世界中仏教広げるどころか
日本でもできないんだから
だから広げればいいななんですけど
そんな妄想にふけってね
毎日の仕事はどうなるんですかね
だから私にとってみれば
世界中広げても広げなくてもどうでもいいんですけど
私は に質問して疑問を持ってる人々
仏教を理解したい人々は
たとえ五 六人であっても
その人々に理解してもらうんです
それで私は五人を成功させているでしょうに
世界に広げたい 世界に広げたいと
何もやってないでしょうに
だからいつでもこの実践にかけてる観念はね
もうゴミだから捨ててほしい
有意義という条件を伴えない思考は有害妄想
有害な妄想であると確認する
あの いくら言っても皆様は頭の中で妄想しますよ
ヴィパッサナー瞑想しても妄想しますよ
これはもう止められないんだからね
で 妄想があっても 有害な妄想をやめてください
有害な妄想っていうのは
人の役に立ちません 自分の役に立ちません
だからネガティブ思考とかね
自分をすごく低く見下す感情的な妄想とか
あれやこれやと汚い思考いっぱいあるでしょ
ああいうのは有害なんです
それだけストップすれば
清らかな思考 妄想でいればいいんです
正思惟 正思護っていうのは
これは八正道の 2つの項目ですね
それを実践するんです
これも簡単ですね 説明は
喋る時最小限にするんです
女性には怒られるかもしれませんだけど
喋る場合は最小限にするんです
それから言葉を選んで喋るんです
口に出た言葉ではなくて
ちょっとリハーサルして
この言葉で良いのかと選んで喋らなくちゃいけないんです
この 1枚で終わると思います
語る時は相手に語るんです
よく覚えてください みんなこのコミュニケーション失敗するのはそれなんです
自分の興奮 感情を言いふらすだけで
相手も生の人間であるということを忘れるんですね
だから自分の感情をどうでもいいんです
相手に語るんです 相手が理解し
理解する用語で語るんです
お釈迦様が行ったような感じで
難しい仏教語たくさんあるんですけど
お釈迦様はいつでも相手に理解してもらって
相手が理解し 理解している用語を使って喋ったんです
だからこれダメですね
つぶやき調子は禁止です
だいたい人間喋ってるとほとんどつぶやきなんですね
なんか自分で喋ってるんだったら黙って喋れよと
喫茶店に行って友達も呼んで
それぞれ自分の世界のことを喋ってるんですね
あれはダメなんですよ
人間ダメになっちゃうんです
このつぶやく調子はダメです
いつでもアイデアがあって
相手に伝えるようにと喋ると
例えば 嫌だな この頃はね
寒気が 寒気がして もう野菜も高くて
もう大変ですね 自分に言ってるでしょ
そんなこと そういう頭が悪くなるんですね
だから野菜が 今 今頃野菜は高くなってますねとかね
普段よりは まあ普段よりは 100円 150
円とか高くなっている場合もありますけど
というと 相手に喋ってるでしょ
この頃野菜もね 高くなっちゃってねとかね
わかりますか？その差が
傑作にしたければ相手に喋ってください
瞑想実践で思考停止の訓練するんです
欠かせないんです ヴィパッサナー瞑想は
テーマがない 心のおしゃべりは人に最大の不幸を招く原子炉なのです
これは結論です テーマがなくて
頭の中でおしゃべりっていうのはもう原子炉だと思ってください
いいわけじゃないんです
だからといって言葉やめるわけにもいきません
仏教はもうただ 行為としての沈黙はもう認めてないんです
精神的沈黙を語っているんです
聖なる沈黙というのは悟りのことなんです
はい 聖者の言葉 このあの
あの宣伝した時のあの
あのあった文章ですね
アビダッカサマータンノサンマサンブッダッササーワコ
アリーエヌトゥンニバーウェーナウペトーホーティターデウェー
このカディラニーカディラワニーレーワタという大阿羅漢がもう寿命終わりまして
亡くなりたいんです 阿羅漢っていうのは自分で決めるんです
はい これから死にますと
それでみんなに発表した場面をもっと芸たくさん美しい芸たくさんありますよ
私は生きることも好まないし
別に死ぬことも好まない精神に達しているんだとか
たくさんなりまって この一つの例なんです
少学者の弟子が無思考
思考しない いわゆる悟り
解脱ですね 無思考に達しました
彼が聖沈黙を具現しているのですと
これ言って その阿羅漢が涅槃に入りました
悟ってますよ 悟ってますよ
悟ってましたよと言ったら
すぐ涅槃に入る時ですね
いうのは遺言として そこまでは言いません
第三人称で自分が最終解脱に達していることを表現しているのです
その場合も第三人称で語るんです
私はないんです もう言語の問題知ってますからね
聖な仏弟子が聖なる沈黙の思考に達しましたよと
本当は自分のことを言ってますけど
自分という言葉さえも使わないんです
お釈迦さんはそうなんです
それでやっと終了ということになります
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
あのだいぶ時間が余分をつけてまいりましたけど
若干の余がございますので
10分ぐらいですけど
もし質問されたい方がいらっしゃいましたら挙手いただいてもよろしいでしょうか
質問をされたい方いらっしゃいます
それでは皆さんよく理解されている
はい では助かりました
はい 今マイク  죄します
お願いします 言葉のリハーサルが済んでないのでまとまってない思考なんですが
えっと 思考妄想が一方的に高騰するという
思考妄想は一方的に高騰する
と 思考妄想するたびに貪瞋痴の煩悩が溜まっていくというお話がありましたけれど
例えば人から相談を受けた時に
あのー お話をする場合
人には相談をした人には怒り
怒りの感情がある場合ですけれど
その怒りを吐き出させてあげるっていうことは
ただ高揚 怒りをさらに増やしているだけに過ぎないのでしょうか
いろいろ相談を受けた時に
なんかとにかくその相手にその気持ちをぶちまけさせるというか
とにかく発散させてから話を
こちらの意見を聞く  あの即席でそういうカウンセリングの方法はありますけど
俺は良くないんです まあカウンセラーがもう全く冷静でいられるならば大丈夫ですけど
まあカウンセラーっていうのはまあ一応仕事ですからね
まあしょうがないし  自分がキャーキャーと怒りの発散してもわからないんで
怒りが消えたかどうかとは
で 例えばね 物を殴ったり叩いたり
壁にぶち当たったりして
もう怒りを発散するでしょ
やっぱり怒り溜まった代償を払っているんです
カウンセラーの前ででも
情けない姿で もう惨めな姿で自分の全部晒し出したりしてとかね
なんでそんな惨めになったのかというと
妄想した結果なんですね
妄想して怒りが溜まったんですね
だからもうかなり代が高くなっているんです
だから まあ怒りなくす方法と感情をなくす方っていうのは
まあ結構世の中でもいろいろありますけど
仏教でもいろいろあって
仏教的な場合はもう一応副作用はないんですね
それから仏教のやり方では
この借金が黒字になるようにしているんです
例えば 怒り欲はもうあって
どうでもいいんだから実況中継するんだそうと思っちゃうと
まるっきり別なこと思考そのものを停止をしているでしょ
その場合はものすごい黒字が上がっているんです
その黒字でこの赤字をもう消せます
そういうのは仏教が推進する方法なんです
例えば あの怒りを本人が相談している人が気がついて
それを理解して いい結論に導くことができたとか
そういう時は心がもうすでに怒りから怒りでない心に変わっているという結果になった場合は
それは無駄で無駄話とは言わない
それは  無駄話じゃない
例えば喋った いわゆる喋ったことで相手の怒りがなくなったならばですか
それで相手の助け 相手は助かっているでしょうね
人のためになっているでしょうね
人のためになる言葉は無駄話じゃないんです
例えば 人が怒りを興奮して発散すると
そうですよ 私もそんな気持ちになりますよと言った途端
ダメでしょうに 怒りを正当化しているでしょうに
だからもうカウンセラーが相手の欲と怒りといろんな感情をなくすように喋るでしょ
それはまあ根拠があってもなくてもいいんです
別に で 私も子供たちの感情が上がってきちゃうと
とんでもないいろんなぐちゃぐちゃな話するんですね
かなりなんていうのはオーバーにしていろんなことを言うんですね
言ってることは嘘と子供たちもわかってますけど
あの話聞きながら落ち着くんですね
結局は 怒らなくなっちゃうんですね
だからまあ人の自分の役に立つか
人の役に立つかということは条件でしょ
喋る場合は  ありがとうございます
他に質問ある方いらっしゃいますか
はい では 回向の文を皆さまでお唱えして終わりしたいと思います
合掌してください  回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝致し
彼らのために比丘の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして争いが出られますように
サッビーティオイワジャンツーサッブローブーウィナッサトーマーテーワヴァッタンタラーヨスティーディーガーユコーババヴァトゥサッブマングラッカントゥサッブ
デヴァタサッブブンダヌバーヴェーナサッブダンマヌバーヴェーナサッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナサタースッティバヴァントゥテーアビワダンシリスサニッチャンヴァ
ッダパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーヴァッダンティアーユワンノーสุขカンバラン
サーリプッタサーリプッタ
ありがとうございます